in this lesson we're going to talk about
probability the probability is
definitely something you want to
understand for the new revised s80 and
basically the formula here that you want
to commit to memory if you don't know
already is that probability is the
number of successes what you want right
divided by the total possible outcomes
the total possible things that it could
occur so it's what you want over the
total right so a lot of times I'm asking
T what they're going to do is they're
going to give you a table and you have
to get the probability by getting the
information from the table okay so in
this particular table that I've created
here you've got students that like math
two different grades that they're in
you've got mail you've got female and so
the question says what is the
probability that a person that chosen at
random from the 10th grade the like math
is a female student okay so go ahead and
pause the video see if you can do this
one is it a B C or D okay again knowing
what we know about probability we say
well of the 10th graders okay there's 90
of them that's the total possible okay
these are the ones that like math right
what's the problem that their female is
30 out of that group so it's 30 / 90 you
could reduce that to one-third so the
probability is one third letter B so
this one wasn't too challenging but
problem but it's really just
understanding you know what probability
is and then picking the important
information out of the data some of the
stakes that students might make they
might say well it's 30 / all of these
female students or they might do 30 out
of the total but in this case we're
looking at this subset of 10th graders
what's the problem it was a female so
it's that what you want out of the total
students in the tenth grade which is 90
so again just remember probabilities
number of successes of the total
possible outcomes in this case the total
possible outcomes which just goes in the
tenth grade that liked math so
definitely important to understand I'll
see you in the next lesson